make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are we're jumping into the
Avengers were jumping back into the
Avengers and this is actually kind of a
one-shot comic but this is interesting
right because I've been getting a lot of
questions from people who were asking
where this particular story fits in with
regards to what's going on in the Iron
Man comics I'm not really sure that it
does and model hasn't really seemed to
consolidate the two things right like
when this takes place chronologically to
the other one we can kind of assume
beforehand or maybe it's after again
it's just kind of one of those weird
things right because if you guys recall
from the Avengers comics Tony Stark's
time-displaced 1 million years before
the modern dates and the Iron Man comics
Tony Stark is an AI Ryan like he's
leading this artificial intelligence
revolt against like the current era
right but then you go when you read The
Avengers comics and he's 1 million years
in the past right so in terms of when
these two take place I don't entirely
know and honestly I'm not really
concerned with reconciling the two at
this point I'm just kind of going with
the flow and eventually it'll be
explained what we won't I don't know but
what this does is this initially picks
up kind of in the past right and it's
kind of cool to see Jason Aaron do this
and this is something you were to kind
of expect to see in the Iron Man comics
but we're not it picks up in the past
and it almost kind of builds off a
little bit with regards to the secret
origin of Tony Stark from Karen Gillan's
run but the idea is that that Tony
essentially kind of you know has these
x-ray contact lenses and ends up
sneaking into this sort of basement in
his parents house or there's this kind
of gathering of all these super wealthy
people and as you would expect and as
most people believe at least the
conspiracy theorists do when it comes to
like the ultra wealthy that they're all
just part of some giant cult but
nonetheless with this particular bunker
here what this is is is basically all
these people who are kind of gathered
together and then doing whatever is
super wealthy people do right and
they're kind of you know giving
themselves up or you know what initially
this kind of conversation of you know
what those who are who are looking to
make an offering you know come forward
what do you have to offer and and some
of them say like we have to offer our
bodies right we have that we have to
offer our flesh and it's kind of like no
you know the master has already you know
already has that what else do you have
to offer and they say we offer our souls
right and then of course somebody comes
out in a big red cloak and then with
Tony sword watching it all when the
cloak head is taken down there basically
it's the if sleight is a person dressed
up as the devil right and for the way
this is done it's kind of been two-fold
the first is to kind of be foreshadowing
and what we're gonna see in the rest of
the story and then the other part of it
is it just scared the heck out of Tony
Stark when he was a little kid and it's
something that he never forgot but what
this does is it kind of jumps you know a
few weeks ago
with regards to Tony Stark being a
million years ago right and so initially
he immediately comes into conflict with
the Avengers 1 million now this is
something easy to overlook but it's
actually something that's hugely
important and the reason why is because
you've basically got star brand 1
million you've got Ghost Rider 1 million
you've got you got Odin and you've got
the Phoenix force now the Phoenix force
doesn't directly fight Tony Stark but
instead over the course of a single page
you have him face off against Ghost
Rider
you haven't faced off against star brand
and then you have a face off against
Odin and he's able to hold his own
against all three of them and that's a
huge thing right that's a huge moment
because Tony Stark has never really
historically been depicted as like the
most powerful Avenger ever right he's
the smartest of all the Avengers but
he's never really been depicted as the
most powerful of all the Avengers ever
even then with his intelligence you get
kind of a mixed bag right if you go when
you read Jonathan Hickman's Avengers a
New Avengers read Richard States on
multiple occasions there are things that
I don't know that I hit Tony Stark up
for right because the guy's the best
person when it comes to developing
machinery different things like that
during Secret Wars for example from 1984
the technology that Tony Stark used for
his Iron Man suit that he gave to James
Rhodes was far beyond anything that like
Reed Richards had imagined creating
right so like in a lot of ways when it
comes to building things Tony Stark's
way beyond read that's why it's
difficult to make a hierarchy of who the
most intelligent person is because it's
contextual and it goes from one story to
the next but being able to hold his own
against like Odin and against our brand
and against Ghost Rider is a pretty big
thing now you could make an argument
that they weren't fighting to kill him
that they were fighting to basically you
know put him down and then ask questions
or whatever but from what we've seen
with Avengers 1 million they don't
really fight to ask questions they fight
to kill right so if they're pretty
hardcore so we can basically just kind
of look at this and say that like Tony
Stark managed to hold his own against
all of the Avengers 1 million
single-handedly which is a big thing
that's a huge moment but ultimately he's
met with the arrival of the Phoenix
force now the Phoenix force you know
immediately recognizes Tony Stark and
knows who he is now on the surface part
of this is because of the fact that the
Phoenix force breeds the mind of Tony
and then realizes he was sitting here by
some kind of power but he wasn't
summoned here by them right and so the
Phoenix force really kind of knows
what's going on but isn't saying
anything now for those two guys you're
probably asking how this is nature of
the Phoenix force right remember the
Phoenix is an omni versal entity right
is all throughout everything and there's
a there's a facsimile of itself that
every single universe that exists out
there
the Phoenix represents all life that has
ever currently does and will ever exist
meaning the Phoenix force exists all
throughout time and space and so
presumably though it's like the way that
dr. Manhattan sees time right dr.
Manhattan sees everything happening all
at the same time the Phoenix force can
largely be assumed to be the same way
right the long and short of this is that
Tony Stark is basically sent away by the
Phoenix because he's essentially going
to undergo these kind of trials and
tribulations that are essentially going
to test this character what the
motivation is behind that we don't know
but the first thing to pop up is a woman
who basically provides him with a kind
of with a kind of food right Tony Stark
turns it down but then after her come
more women and every day there's more
and more women after that when he turns
them down then come various cavemen
bearing clubs and of course he turns
them down as well but ultimately gets
into a bit of a fight with him but again
is able to kind of hold his own wanting
to understand is the energy of Tony
Stark's suit is not limitless right it's
not like it's powered by the Sun or
something like that it would make more
sense of it was because no matter where
he was in the timestream he'd always
have energy for a suit but it may be one
of those things where the Sun just
doesn't have enough power to power suit
right like solar energy just isn't
enough to power the kind of equipment
that his suit has which would be kind of
cool actually and pretty impressive if
that were the case but at the end of the
day is one of these things where he's
constantly kind of visited by these
various presences until ultimately he's
visited by a snake and the snake really
kind of has this interesting way of
talking you know where basically it
addresses him as Tony Stark
he says I'm a very old friend you know
and Tony's like I have no idea who you
are and he's like well we haven't really
met yet you know but we will you know
I'm kind of beyond time you know with
these sort of things and that's where it
gets really interesting because for
those of you guys who were familiar with
Marvel Comics who've been reading for a
long time just going by the speech
bubbles you immediately know who this is
I picked up on it like that I was like I
know exactly who this is but it's one of
these things where you just kind of like
he asks a question do you know how the
smartest person you know how someone
becomes the smartest person in the world
like how do you how did you get to where
you work right how did you get to being
super intelligent you know like there
was a price that was paid for this but
you don't know what that price was and
you don't know how much it cost Howard
Stark would it cost him a price but
though the result he says is basically
you belong to me right no matter what
era you will always belong to me and
it's kind of a crazy thing because Tony
Stark looks at this kind of here's
what's going on and then rejects the
Serpent and sends it you know since it
flying away but after
that suddenly all these things start
popping up right one of the big things
to happen here is you have this guerilla
that shows up wielding the power stone
right the power Infinity stone how it
got it is never explained to us but
we're explicitly told this gorilla is
wielding the power stone now it
absolutely pummeled Tony Stark basically
leaves his armor almost completely and
totally drained and destroyed and then
leaves right doesn't really kill him it
just leaves the idea I guess is to leave
him for dead but those of you guys who
are who are looking at this you guys are
beginning to notice a trend the Tony
Stark is being met with all this
temptation right he's being met by this
idea of you know him him being tempted
to do things to get involved in things
right to take part in various things
that if he gives in to this kind of
temptation that ultimately things can go
south right and so with these serpents
continually showing back up again right
continually popping back up being
resurrected after they die that Tony
Stark essentially assembles you know
takes all these different these
different icicles and then assembles
like the Iron Man ice armor which is
actually pretty cool uses some of the
mechanical components from his existing
Iron Man suit and they're just kind of
fuses it all together into just one big
ice armor like one big ice suit but
ultimately you know it's one of these
things were like this presence it kind
of appears out of nowhere yet again and
essentially says like you know you will
know well enough are like you know
exactly who I am and he says hello Tony
and that's what it's basically revealed
that is Howard Stark and that's kind of
the crazy theme because what we end up
learning is that in this instance back
in Tony's flashback when he was a little
kid and he saw the person who was
wearing the devil mask that he
recognized it was his father that his
father was part of this kind of demonic
cult's more or less but when Tony goes
to attack him starts shooting you know
icicles into this guy's chest which is
kind of kind of crazy of course he just
picks him out and throws him away and
that's what we start to realize there's
more going on here right like there's a
lot more taking place here and
ultimately when this guy reveals who he
really is when Tony shoots him in the
face with an icicle the guy basically
coming you know stands back up again
resurrects himself and then reveals
himself to be Mephisto and that's why
all these different temptations have
been showing up to Tony because the
devil has been trying to get Tony to
give in so that he can in turn receive
Tony's soul but that's the crazy thing
about this is because everything that
Mephisto is essentially saying they
already has the soul of Tony Stark right
like he already owns his soul and and
what we end up having what we end up
finding out is that not only is Mephisto
here Mephisto is in in possession of the
time stone so we don't know how he got
it right and that's when we important
things to understand here when I
to the Infinity stones we're rarely ever
told how it is that a person came into
possession of them what are the only
real instances that we have from that is
like when Reed Richards for example
assembled the Infinity Gauntlet um
during the events of Brian Michael
Bendis is Illuminati storyline or like
when Thanos gained the Infinity stones
from Thanos Qwest storyline leading up
into Infinity Gauntlet which i think is
kind of cool because the sort of gives
us underlying theme that like the
Infinity stones are shifting hands all
the time in Marvel Comics is just we
never really know who's got one from one
moment to the next I think is really
cool but using the power of the time
stone which my Fisto doesn't really need
because he's so incredibly powerful he
ends up like swimming Tony back to the
modern era and with that being the case
he immediately ends up landing in Las
Vegas and basically ends up coming to
this realization like he's back in the
modern era you know he ends up you know
tracking down Mephisto who you know as
far as we can tell is still locked away
in in Las Vegas after the events of
where's the Doctor Strange damnation I
think it was but Mephisto was
essentially locked away in Vegas like
literally in like a cell you know he
just could not escape from uh but
basically it's one of these things where
it's kind of like Tony's like you know
you're never gonna have my soul that
kind of a thing now reading between the
lines here what seems to have gone on
what seems to have taken place kind of
building on Karen Gillan's the secret
origin of Tony Stark is that those are
you guys who remember that story if you
don't I'll have a link to the Iron Man
playlist down in the description so you
can kind of get caught up and know what
we're talking about here but in the
secret origin of Tony Stark essentially
we learned that like the biological
child of Howard a Maria is not Tony that
it's actually Arnold and Arno is
legitimately super intelligent right his
genes were modified during the the
gestation process so that he would be
the smartest person in the world but his
genes were further modified by Howard
and Maria because they didn't trust
recorder 451 who originally modified the
genes and and ultimately their child you
know owner was born without the ability
to basically use his body right he was
born as a complete and total appear who
I guess uh you know paraplegic or
quadriplegic really his entire body was
paralyzed with the exception of his head
right I mean you know everything above
the neck he was fine uh but the result
of this is that that Tony Stark was
adopted in order to kind of maintain the
cover and kind of keep our nose
existence secret but we never really got
an answer to the question how it is at
Tony's just that damn smart and
initially we just kind of were left to
this idea that he's just naturally that
intelligent right he just has an
aptitude right learning at the at the
knee of his father with all of his
father's intelligence and all the
resources of Stark Industries and the
education
to receive that basically he just was
naturally gifted to these kind of things
right but like graduating from MIT at
like 14 15 or 16 years old whatever it
is you know and that kind of stuff
that's beyond the normal scope of just a
really really good education bought by
really wealthy parents right that's
there's some kind of third element at
play there right and what this does is
it really kind of hints towards this
idea that in order for Tony Stark to
essentially become as intelligent as as
Arno was supposed to be that that
basically Tony's soul was sold right
now's really kind of seems to be the
case either Howard sold his own soul or
Tony's soul was sold later on down the
line to Mephisto by Howard Stark and so
what this really points the idea to is
that Tony is doomed to hell for all
eternity right like that's the way that
works when it comes to Mephisto when you
make a barter with Mephisto usually he
tricks you and then you don't believe
and get what you asked for you get some
variation of it and you're usually worse
off than you were before
but regardless once you die Mephisto
takes your soul to his realm in hell
right that's that's where all those
people go as where dr. Doom's mother
went that's where all those people go to
buy those individuals who who barter
with Mephisto and die their souls are
taken by him directly and the kind of
indication here is either that Howard or
Tony or both will end up going to that
location not only that and that's kind
of the crazy thing that goes on here you
have this kind of disembodied voice out
of nowhere that asks Mephisto did you
really believe that Tony was going to
like come here and like talk to you and
reason with you and understand you and
possibly even you know make a deal with
you or anything like that and ultimately
Mephisto says I never intended for him
to make a deal I never intended for
anything to do that what I've done here
is I've sown doubt and feared and this
will ripple outward and presumably
effect you know it'll it'll cross
multiple worlds and it will affect a
multitude of different people it kind of
seems to be a bigger game at foot we
don't really know what this bigger game
is but what we do know is that the
person talking to Mephisto is actually
none other than Howard Stark himself now
whether or not this is really Howard
Stark we don't know it may be one of
these things where it's just somebody
masquerading as him or it's just like a
projection or something along those
lines but it really seems to actually be
him it actually really seems to be
Howard Stark who's somehow either back
or resurrected from the dead or
something along those lines but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain and make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob for if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
Prue's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]